how I would launch a no strip business
if I were to launch one so they
currently sell for about 30 cents a
strip they probably cost a penny or less
to make 19.99 would probably be a price
point that I would look at maybe 24.99 I
would you know we'd split test the price
points there and I'd probably sell 30 60
90 packs but let's do the math on how
much money this would make if I just did
my own promotion let's say 10 000 people
a month would go to a page if I said hey
check this out and then we converted
five percent of traffic then we would
have 500 buyers 10 churn that means that
every month I would sign up 500 and then
I'd lose 10 percent this business would
keep growing with that level of traffic
until we reached 5 000 users because
it's 500 divided by 10 which is the
churn I would be at 5 000 users a month
and if my price point was twenty dollars
so I'd probably make like they safely
even after the cost of the no strips
which is minimal let's just say we make
16 gross margin on a 20 product eighty
thousand dollars a month million dollars
a year in profit from the no strips